hey guys I'm KJ well hey guys I'm Britt
and we are with BuzzFeed and we're about
to see how well we know each other yeah
so the first one is their favorite snack
at crafty I know that one but it's
limited and like a crafty situation is
limited I'll go this yeah what mountains
you oh that's really good yeah yeah yeah
that's very good I don't know some sort
of like a health protein situation like
a protein bar maybe like a protein bar
yeah you're right no I don't know if
that's right you're right cuz that's my
go to their dressing room must have
Mountain Dew wow these are very good
answers and it's true it's very true
this is pretty good but I don't know if
you'll think this is accurate I drew for
your birthday people just started
bringing in lighters by the fold
activity between filming scenes Mountain
Dew Mountain Dew I mean no go to
activity between filming scenes I feel
like you you just chill between sings
chill kind of go yeah why usually have
my dog so go like walk them perhaps just
like to relax I just like to relax be at
peace I got a ride yes you got it right
I feel like it's like a workout of some
sort maybe it's like push-ups or
something maybe it's like running about
oh maybe doing like an Instagram thing
where you're like doing photos with
people and they think it's a photo but
really it's just a video right you did
that a lot yeah I think it changes for
me I'm gonna go with yes I got it right
you got our you got it okay their last
project before the one you worked on
together riverdale correct Mountain Dew
commercial yeah can't do it the person
who visited them most on set
oh your mom yeah she's there Yo Ma
they're the exact same time spa together
I did yeah I'm going to the spa together
they're acting medium preference film TV
commercial theater etc yeah you like TV
don't you I do love TV I think that's
right out of all of them yeah yeah I
feel like you like movies out of all of
them yell or I roll them yep you're
right
their favorite movie you can do this I
can do this once I can do this maybe I
can do this I don't we just I know we
just did this we just did this what we
did also learn in that moment is we're
not great at listening to each other
you'll just play with him yeah I know
what's yours like with an English woman
in it ah it's a romantic comedy AHA but
she's not English their name sounded J
uh-huh
Juliet so close Julia Roberts it's so
hot in here right it's hardening I'm
sweetie calm down is yours like I know
no is it dumb and dumber
yes Wow big win big win big win big win
think we first time you met feel like we
know that their birth year okay so this
one I feel like I can help you a little
bit so I'm about to but yeah really big
this years already know I already not
big birthday year for know okay yeah I
think so you're right 97 97 no 1990 very
good yeah cuz I'm turning how old so
soon 30 30 I'm not gonna I don't know at
least leave it I don't want to yeah I
think it's in June it's turn yeah their
hometown which actually it's not your
home yeah Carolina yeah yeah it's close
no come on don't care what it's for well
is it where I was born or where well
your hometown yeah well I mean all three
judges and you will Oakland Oakland yep
so I'm telling ya okay
middle name easy yeah no I know
yours is Liana no but yeah Vienna yeah
Vienna oh sorry so yours
Teddy James Fitzgerald James Fitzgerald
is that all planet got it coffee Oda
yeah I forget it okay hold on I can do
this
you don't really drink coffee you drink
Mountain Dew yeah I don't really like
coffee that much but yours is like what
is it oh you're just like that like
black coffee not nothing else yeah um
another character that you've portrayed
I don't even know you played in dogs I
don't even remember
name's Ethan and their hidden talent
there's nothing really that hidden what
the guitar playing but we don't hide
things from each other
really it's open I mean he's great at
guitar that's a good one feel like I get
that some people might not know if they
don't follow them on the ground or just
my hidden talent you love to dance and
you're a good dancer
thank you hidden talent I think too is
singing you know how to sing but not
many people know that's right 14 has 16
won't you go 12 that's pretty good
though but I won you did win yeah well
thanks BuzzFeed thanks cheers man till
next time
till next time Siana
[Music]